we all have powers we are almost out of
the supercollider you all that sucked
out of your own dimension if we don't
destroy the collider none of us will
have a home to go home to let's go save
the world
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody is Charlie we got to talk
about that spider-man into the
spider-verse post-credit scene in the
end of the movie they set up some really
big things pay off some big Easter eggs
and they're just really funny on top of
everything we're also doing a new round
of that imax ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from the
movie on the video obviously careful for
spoilers if you have not seen spider-man
into the spider-verse yet because we'll
be talking about what happens at the end
of the movie so here we go what I'm
gonna do is is I'm gonna talk about the
post-credits scene first because it sort
of clarifies what's happening at the
actual end of the movie the end of the
movie itself sort of tees up what's
going to be happening with the sequel
the post-credits scene just provides
some more context for that in addition
to just being a really funny moment so
in the post-credits scene you go to
nueva york and you see Oscar Isaac from
Star Wars and a billion other things
playing Miguel O'Hara
spider-man 2099 in his full comic book
costume he's creating the web where
watches from the spider-verse comics
that they used to traverse the web of
life and destiny without people's help
like Madame web so he creates the watch
that allows him to independently travel
between universes and says all right
back to the beginning and they go back
to the spider-man 1967 original TV
series to recreate this moment of
spider-man pointing at each other so
they go back to basically recreate a
gift that you've probably been seeing
all over the internet for the past year
because of all the spider-man's stuff
that's been going on that man is the
imposter
[Music]
hold on a second we'll have a showdown
to prove which of us is the real
spider-man and you can unmask the loser
that's fair enough but no tricks so it's
just a really funny moment if you've
never seen that episode it's spider-man
1967 season 1 episode 19 be the title is
double identity and is basically just
spider-man catching a thief in the act
committing a bunch of crimes dressed up
masquerading as spider-man so like they
do earlier in the film they jump between
different animation styles within the
film so in the 2099 scene when Miguel
O'Hara is getting ready to use the watch
to travel back in time he's animated the
same way the other regular characters
are during spider-verse but when he
travels back to 1967 in that cartoon
he's the animated like the 1967 cartoon
so it's just a really funny moment but
essentially what they're telling you is
is because this is real is that he's
creating the web wear watches which is
how they'll accomplish their future
crossovers so in the movie it's kingpin
creating a device so that he can
actually bring his family back from
another universe so his giant machine
starts collapsing universes into each
other which causes the other versions of
spider-man like spider-gwen spider-man
noir Peter porker to fall through the
multiverse into Miles Morales earth but
the longer they stay there more their
body has become unstable because they
weren't meant to be in other people's
universes it's implied that the web
where watches that Miguel O'Hara is
creating in 2099
will solve that issue or really a number
of issues one so that they can just
basically crossover between universes in
future sequels without having to create
a giant machine like the kingpin again
and so that their bodies won't start
glitching out when they're in other
universes like they did during the movie
like every time you would see them in a
fight every once in a while they glitch
out and it would really hurt them when
they were trying to fight a villain so
if it wasn't too clear going back to the
end of the actual movie though you see
Miles lying in bed listening to that
song and all a sudden a portal opens
above his head and his gwen stacy
spider-gwen looking down at him saying
hey miles and he's getting ready to talk
to her so it's implied that she also now
has one of those watches so even though
that 2099 spider-man timeline might seem
a little confusing
they already
confirmed that the sequel will be miles
in spider-gwen
they haven't said which other characters
will come back but I'm assuming that
most of the mains from spider-verse will
return for the sequel like Jake
Johnson's Peter B Parker the last we saw
him he was getting ready to heal his
relationship with his version of Mary
Jane so in another two or three years
when they get that sequel out he'll have
finished healing his relationship with
Mary Jane maybe they'll have a baby on
the way and that baby can be made a
Parker the other big easter egg in that
post-credits scene the web where watches
from the comics is is that in the comics
those watches are the workaround for
madam web but there are also a big story
device for the other larger community of
spider people when Peter Parker in Miles
Morales or in other comic book titles
having other adventures so originally
they were created so that people like
Spider Woman Jessica drew could assemble
her own team of other spider people and
they could have their own multiverse
team-up title without the help of Peter
Parker or Miles Morales would have
surprised that a couple weeks ago Sony
confirmed that they're doing another
spin-off film to into the spider verse
and it's going to be an all female
spider people team-up they didn't say
what the story is going to be but they
did confirm it was inspired by the
spider women Jessica drew team-up comic
book so you have people like spider-gwen
penny Parker Jessica drew may Parker
maybe they'll do a version of Madame web
you also have silk pretty much every
female character you could imagine
there's not that many female spider
people in the spider verse but spider
gedan has been increasing those numbers
exponentially my favorite new one is
spiders man just literally a Spider Man
that's a costume filled with thousands
upon thousands of tiny spiders made to
look like an actual person walking
around if you stayed for the credits the
other big thing that happened it was
more of a funny moment but it was Chris
Pines Peter Parker the one that died
with the blond hair and the blue eyes
singing his Christmas song but then it
kind of turned into a larger parody of
himself when he started singing about
why am i singing this I have a chemical
engineering degree why did I agree to do
this stupid song the whole movie was
filled to the brink with Easter eggs
there were millions of it's gonna take
forever to find every single one but
most of you probably spotted the really
big ones I will be doing an Easter Egg
video for the biggest ones in the next
couple of days but one of my favorites
was at the beginning of the movie
when the chris pine spider-man was
narrating his backstory and said I also
did this and he's walking down the
street doing the Tobey Maguire dance
from spider-man 3 that got one of the
biggest laughs in my theater but let me
know in the comments they have a whole
bunch of spin-offs planned where do you
want to see spider-man 2099 show up
again do you want him to get his own
spin-off movie or do you just want to
see him during the sequel the producers
of the movie said that they literally
talked about doing every possible thing
you could imagine they wanted to bring
back Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
to do voices for characters but the
powers that be at Sony and Marvel just
told them to hold off like save stuff
for sequels so I do think at some point
we will get Tobey Maguire in Andrew
Garfield voicing characters inside a
spider-verse movie this is a clip of
Andrew Garfield reflecting on his time
as spider-man which is pretty rare you
don't hear Tobey Maguire spending a lot
of time reflecting on his era of
spider-man but it's a lot of fun to
listen to him talk about it young I was
young and I think it's a it's a it's a
it's a difficult and you know not as
young as someone like you know the young
guy playing it now Tom Hall news a
fantastic by the way
but I think the something that there is
something that happens in those I don't
know what your experience was but my
experience is something that happens
there's something that happened with
that experience for me where it was
story and character were actually not
top of the priority list ultimately yeah
and I think that's I found that really
really tricky I signed up to serve the
story and so this incredible character
that I've been dressing s since I was
three yeah and then there's the it gets
compromised and it breaks breaks you I
praise my heart I got I got heartbroken
a little bit to a certain degree
[Applause]
[Music]
so Andrew Garfield and Toby McGuire come
back but here's the thing who would you
want them to voice if they do characters
do you want them to do other versions of
spider-man or would you want them to
voice nods spider-man characters because
like they have a six one six universe
inside the spider verse you could just
say that their movies occurred in
different universes so they did think
about canonizing the events of all those
movies into the actual animated
spider-verse and they're close to doing
that with the MCU as well
but it'd be more of a joke and you'd
actually have to get one of the actors
from The Avengers to voice their
character to legitimize that Tom Holland
doing an animated version of his
spider-man would probably be enough to
accomplish that you just had to have him
show up in his own stark tech suit so
that you would know is him and there was
a lot of love for some of the suits from
the games like spider-man ps4 they had
the advanced suit there'll be a lot of
that that I'll cover in my Easter Egg
video but leave all your requests in the
comments below click here for my
non-spoilery review of the movie and
click here to check out that new batman
vs robin titans trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]